I want to talk about this story from CNN
DC grand jury that handed up 2020
election indictment against Trump meets
again now there's a lot of speculation
that they're going to be meeting again
because more indictments are going to be
handed down against Donald Trump but
there is also speculation they're now
going to go after Giuliani and the and
what they refer to as unindicted
co-conspirators in Donald Trump's uh
what do they call it a criminal fraud
against the United States so it looks
like there's a there's a likelihood I
think it makes more sense they're going
to go after those quote unquote
conspirators uh what they actually mean
is Trump's lawyers they're going to go
after the people who gave Trump legal
counsel
this is a indicative of the expansion of
the weaponization of government despite
the fact that the Republicans are
supposedly probing the weaponization of
the doj they're just ramping all of this
up but Tom I'm wondering I'm wondering
what you think about this what are they
doing
well they're escalating there's been no
check there's been no consequence for
this abuse uh for the justice department
or the FBI or everyone else involved
here you have Democrats in Georgia about
to indict trump it looks like get the
Democrats in New York indict Trump and
and what they're trying to do is is
freeze the Republican Party in the
run-up to the election uh by saying not
only is the candidate and the former
president but people around him the
consultant class your campaign lawyers
activists involved in advising you as to
how to handle election disputes they're
subject to being thrown in jail if this
indeed this is the case that they end up
getting indicted and I think that's
probably going to be true you know I
testified to the grand jury back in
February they they sent the FBI knocking
on our door not my my home in November
and you know what the Judicial Watch do
well we were out there publicly talking
about how the Mar-A-Lago case was a sham
since they changed their position on
presidential records from the Clinton
software case that we have been involved
in and changed it completely to go after
Trump came up with new rules and so
complete retaliation and then they then
they spent three hours questioning me
about emails and such about presidential
electors and I you know and I told them
I said well I don't understand what's
going on here Democrats challenged and
had alternative slates of electors in
1960. so I guess it's different for
Republicans Nixon chose to ignore the
certified electors instead he chose the
Democrat alternate slate to be counted
and they were counted yeah yes so and on
top of that
um I told the grand jury and the three I
had three prosecutors questioning me so
it was a triple team uh on on me and
they were
I I told them that I I was concerned in
the summer of 2020 because I read about
it in New York Times the Democrats were
planning uh succession threats of
secession and Civil War if the Electoral
College went towards Trump and I said
well you know of course obviously that
isn't going to be investigated by this
justice department and obviously and
what I saw from this from this Grandeur
experience that I had was I was in a
political argument with these
prosecutors about First Amendment
protected activity and I was just
sitting there thinking why am I being
questionable this is a political debate
why did they question you why did they
call you in
I was harassment and retaliation
Judicial Watch is the number one
litigator against the justice department
we criticized the justice department we
sued for records about their abuse of
trump they know who we are they know who
I am and we were the top voice in
calling them out and it drove them crazy
and of course the big accusation was
well Trump was listening to Tom fitton
what you know it's just all all sorts of
um
imagine if the head of the ACLU was
called in because of the work he was
doing at the ACLU that's what they did
to Judicial Watch and of course we don't
get the protection and media support
that the ACLU gets but frankly our work
is more consequential that's why the
justice department was harassing and
abusing us so what I saw happen at that
grand jury was abused and I'll tell you
one quick story
so that at one point the prosecutor said
to me so are you going to talk about
this
to anyone what what happened here I said
I don't know I said it's you know I had
to talk to our lawyers but that's a
privilege are you going to talk about
this to anyone I said I don't know it's
publicly out there are you going to talk
about this to anyone I said I don't know
he said well oh by the way
I thought uh you're you're allowed to
talk about it and I said you know
frankly given your questions it was
pretty intimidating and chilling so this
guy was trying to get me to swear under
oath to something I didn't have to do
which was to keep quiet on these this
abuse of power that I was facing so I
just I saw this guy was trying to Corner
me into swearing under oath that I
wasn't going to talk so that was in my
view outrageous prosecutorial abuse I'm
still ticked about it and I hope the
courts take care of it in the end I have
no surprise they I have no surprise no
surprise that Trump was indicted after
what I saw there and you know the grand
jury's sitting there
I I don't know the cultural divide in
this country is is
unsalvageable as far as I'm concerned
the the judge in DC that you right now
they're trying to stop Trump from being
able to speak during a political
campaign while they used the case
against him to campaign the only way you
look at this judge in in Minnesota who's
sentencing these cops to prison these
leftist judges don't care about what
Justice means they don't care about
fairness they care about power they're
not judges they're they're effectively
up they're uh occupying forces placed in
these roles for the purpose of
destroying anyone who opposes them I
mean if the judges were honest
I don't know if honest is the right word
if I were a judge I said you know what
I'm not playing your game you're trying
to make me interfere in elections I'm
not going to do it your case is paused
you come back to me in November or
December or January of next year then
we'll talk about what we're going to do
but in the meantime we're not going to
use my courtroom to litigate the
campaign and I'm not going to start
telling president Trump that he can't
defend himself as Jack Smith made a
political statement last week talking
about how Trump was responsible for the
overthrow the tempted overthrow of the
government and all the violence on
Capitol Hill for which he wasn't even
charged Jack Smith should be the one on
the dock if the judges were acting
appropriate because he said it it was
true with he didn't say allegedly he
just said the crime he did the crime
without the prosecutorial uh due
diligence well I mean I think that's a
charitable way of putting it uh but he
came out and suggested that Trump was
behind violence and he was promoting the
indictment and you know as folks who are
smarter about this if explained you know
a prosecutor can't come out and say you
know read the indictment that's the
truth well that's that's not what a
prosecutor does a prosecutor supposed to
say read the indictment and all the
evidence behind it both inculpatory the
stuff that makes the guy look bad and
exculpatory and so to say anything else
is infecting the jury pool so there's
one man who infected the jury pool in my
view that hasn't been held accountable
and that's Jack Smith
and of course don't even get started in
all the leaks that have been I think
fairly attributed to the justice
department of grand jury material now
the problem is for I think conservatives
and even Libertarians to to a great
degree
post-liberals whatever this faction is
keep thinking we're playing a game of
Monopoly and we got to roll the dice see
if we can get ahead meanwhile they're
just pulling bills out of the bank and
doing whatever they want yeah it's like
a game of Monopoly where the goal of the
game is to be the most popular person in
the room doesn't matter if you win the
board game well you can stand up and
flip the table and sing a song and if
everyone looks at you and starts
clapping you win but that's that's I
completely disagree that's not even it
that's what this called you said the
culture bifurcation you were talking
about I agree there's no way to but get
one of those pieces to win you need to
create something new that is so Dynamic
what I'm saying is Imagine playing a
board game where you keep playing by the
rules and your opponent is cheating
right in front of you telling you
they're gonna cheat they keep doing it
and you just keep playing yeah sounds
like those aren't really the rules well
in the case of the Republicans on the
hill they're funding it yeah I mean
there's not a thing the Justice
Department's doing that I'm complaining
about that isn't getting
funding plus by the Republican house uh
leadership and so they have a decision
over the next few months whether they're
going to defund Jack Smith they're not
defund the censorship they won't but you
know but don't but but don't let anyone
tell you they can't do anything about
what is going on with the attack on
Trump so Trump is going to get jailed
I think potentially there's a good
chance that happens Americans are being
censored all this other abuse is taken
taking place with the full funding and
by Republicans and they are saying well
maybe legislation next year but right
now we're being hurt and they could shut
it down tomorrow but they're on vacation
there's a seven week they're in a seven
week the middle of a seven week vacation
that is unconscionable for the American
government to vacate for seven weeks at
a time when you have the internet you
guys get back to work what in the hell
I'm Clint you're about to say something
awesome
no I was just gonna say
um you know I don't I don't actually get
that upset with Jack spit Jack Smith is
a Hitman for the regime that dude's
doing his job what I'm upset with are
the the conservatives that have had an
entire session in which they could have
defanged and and defunded so much of
this nonsense and they opted not to
where are they they don't even want to
impeach Biden there's not enough
evidence I mean it's like that it's like
msnbc's running the Republican house
caucus in terms of being their
fearfulness and proceeding with the
impeachment inquiry against body what
would be the process if the Republicans
were to defund this process like what
would that look like who would say what
how would it move forward you would say
the justice department can't spend any
money Prosecuting any presidential
candidate you could name the person
um you know prior to whatever date
they're you know you know their their
scribes on the hill that write the
language out to prevent the funding of
Jack Smith they can actually defund
people by name so anyone who's been
listed in terms of censoring Americans
they can be defunded and believe me I've
been raising this since Republicans came
into power and Congress can do this go
ahead Congress can do this without
without the Senate without the president
they can just control the person on
their own correct the house has to be
willing to go to the mat on this and and
by going to the mat is the Republicans
aren't the Senate isn't going to want to
buy into this yeah but they need the
support of the house in order to keep
the government funded and so there's
going to be a a fight and probably the
fall over whether to continue funding of
the government because they won't get
all the Appropriations bills out and
there'll be one gargantuan bill that has
to be voted on in order to keep the
government operating for either a month
or whatever period they agree and only
with the acquiescence of the house would
that happen and so in order to get that
acquiescence they could say this is what
we want and if they're not willing to
say that that just tells you where they
stand on on these on this crisis we're
facing this isn't a political debate
when you're trying to jail a form former
president and the current candidate
you're you're kind of you know you're
leaving the Constitution behind
practically speaking and the test here
is you know it wasn't like Trump did
something it's like well he robbed the
bank you know we don't know what the law
is there here they have these novel
applications of the law
not only in New York but in both cases
against him in the federal government
certainly down in Georgia and that tells
you that they had them they targeted him
and they tried to figure out how to jail
him you know
because they had picked them as a Target
the document was the worst dude
because Biden had documents too like let
it alone yeah Hillary Clinton had
documents what the well and and
they'll also Russia Russian collusion
and then uh I think it was actually
today or yesterday that you have the FBI
agent that's now getting prosecuted for
Russia and he was the one that lied to
get uh the investigation started on
Trump in the first place it's unreal
everything they do James Lindsey iron
level uh iron level projection yeah did
you see incredible there was a tweet
from like was it the Secretary of State
no it was I was just like is this satire
they were like we we condemn the Russian
behavior of silencing the opponent
political okay was that blinking it was
and I was like is this is what they're
doing Donald Trump right now is the
exact same thing what an embarrassment
you know Putin and G look at this and
they must say who who are they kidding
America is different and they they
pretend they're different Putin
recognizes what's going on with Trump
she recognizes what's going on with
Trump
yeah but we're but you know the the you
know the idiot class it runs DC they
pretend there's a serious crime that's
being charged here everyone else sees
well the guy's a little he's arrested
his political opponent what else do you
need
well and this this is what you know uh
Russia gets or put gets dragged through
the mud for is exactly what's
transpiring in America right now which
is going after your political opponents
and jailing people for speech and
Reporting and all these other things
it's like everything we blame Russia for
we're guilty of if not worse it's
incredible and and Biden can shut it
down he's the president of the United
States and if he was honest and ethical
he said you know what guys I I don't
care what crimes you've come up with I'm
not arresting my opponent we're not
Prosecuting him no yeah
and he's constitutionally unable to do
that but instead we found out on the
documents case the Biden White House
intervened at Key times to keep the case
going against Trump and harassing him so
but when it comes to this arrest of
trump now twice by his administration
Biden is ultimately responsible thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time